[Musique]
j'ai commencé avec une trempette
mais en plus du lait empoisonné et cette
personne veut empoisonner
c'est une pente cette personne que j'ai
en trois zones et c'est une parente
ça fait beaucoup appel de rouge les
espoirs il ya des moments donnés mais il
faut bien si le vibrio et ce soir j'ai
décidé de nous parler du crime
ce soir je veux parler de quelque chose
que nous utilisons quotidiennement
je vous parle de quelque chose il ya les
pratiques qui une fois coloris qui lui
servant balej qui nous servent à faire
beaucoup de choses et ce soir je vais me
parmi deux enfants je vous entends pas
alors vous voyez tout ce que je suis en
train de sortir l'armement cris c'est le
sachet plastique c'est le sachet phase
classique parce que joe j'avais une
pente malades à la maison j'ai cherché
partout à cotonou de la casse pour
gagner elle était malade et tout ce
qu'elle voulait c'était de las casas
pour ceux qui connaissent pas la cas ça
c'est une boule de miles itunes
nourriture que nous mangeons
habituellement cette nourriture et en
valais
dans une feuille de pec dans une feuille
de banane et j'ai mis 45 minutes pour
chercher cette nourriture ou ma tante ou
de 45 minutes
d'ailleurs pas trouvé sebulba castel que
je connaissais j'ai été obligé de lui
acheter cette nourriture puis dans ce
sachet plastique pour ceux qui ne le
savent pas ce sachet plastique est
fabriqué avec du pétrole on imagine
heurts mortels à ce résidu de migrants
on a rajouté beaucoup d'éléments
chimiques et ce sachet est sorti quand
nous voyons en allant de toutes les
couleurs on a l'air de toutes les
tailles
ce sachet plastique malheureusement nous
emballons et nous puisons nos aliments
la dent et pourtant il est fabriqué avec
du pétrole
les médecins disent qu en contact avec
les aliments
ce sachet va transférer son adn à
l'aliment de nogent
les médecins disent que ce sachet en
contact avec la nourriture cause du
cancer corps des problèmes d'infertilité
quand nous mêmes les problèmes sur la
peau
et pourtant nous l'utilisons au
quotidien
un soir où je regardais ma tante manger
ses moules de gaza je suis resté et je
suis dit les promesses que points 3 qui
ce que le sachet est dangereux comment
est-ce que trois puits ont pu céder
comment est ce que toi tu peux nourrir
quelqu'un avec un aliment empoisonné
promesse q3 qui peut céder à la facilité
savez dans la vie
3 à certaines situations la facilité ces
deux blâmes et d'autres consoles c'est
vrai j'aurais public tout le monde
j'aurais plus blâmer la bande 2,6 parce
que n aurait dû remballer sa nourriture
dans une feuille de paie j'aurais pu en
bleu j'aurais pu glaner les premières
semblent les distributeurs les épiciers
qui envoie est perçu leur insu c'est une
heure j'aurais pu blague
l'idée qui malgré craint que ces sachets
sont ainsi qu un seulement pour la santé
mais pour l'environnement continue pas
fermer les yeux sur ce commerce
j'aurais pu bien mais tout le monde mais
ce soir deux semaines après ce crime
parce que je n'arrivais pas à dormir je
me suis lancé un défi et ce défi c'est
la taille ça chez les loups et je vends
du stage chez séché pour ceux qui ne
comprennent pas ri lwin et un loup et
dans notre langue en fongbé c'est une
interjection nous disent on rit on est
face à un danger souvent d'un pôle oil
danger ans mais elle avait su la tête et
mon dieu les louer c'est pour montrer la
dangerosité c ou monter le catastrophe
c'est pour rentrer
danger que nous avons face à l'autre
j'ai lancé sur attaque parce qu'il est
temps que nos citoyens
il est temps que nos populations nous
prenions nous aussi nos responsabilités
ce sachet plastique
vous savez quoi il est fabriqué en
dessus bron je vis bien deux secondes
son utilisation d'urnes en moyenne 20
minutes
il savait premier l'avait arrêté après
nos chers en vaucluse 400 amis
imaginez 400 années après vous donc
après la baule dakar 1 400 années ce
sachet va rester dans la nature mais il
n'est pas dans la nature juste pour nous
regarder
il est dans la nature non seulement il
nous a posé de temps à notre santé mais
dans la nature ils bouchent nos
canalisations
il est sous nos terres aujourd'hui
l'agriculture dont pays de marge quand
même des engrais chimiques
kamel de pesticides nos sommes produise
plus à ce que malheureusement nos sols
sont elles faites et des sachets
plastiques un tacticien discussions
devraient utiliser tous les sachets
utilisé au bénin le 111 millions de
béninois en moyenne chaque béninois
utilise quelqu'un peut imaginer en
moyenne chaque béninois m'utilise 10 en
chine par jour 10 à g par jour parce que
au bénin
nous utilisons auront aimé pas seulement
belle et nous utilisons le sachet
plastique pour tous nous emballons
johann hay nahda nous pensons tous avec
une d'ailleurs si je veux faire un petit
exercice je vais juste vous donner
quelques secondes
regardez dans le sac nous avons toujours
le sachet avec nous et donc dix sachets
plastiques par jour est ce que nous
faisons même au besoin dans ces sachets
elle saisit que si nous devons utiliser
les chèques que nous utilisons tous les
jours
kraft 11 millions de m sobre sur 365
jours faites le calcul
nous aurions nous pourrons tapissé de la
superficie du bénin mais en cette couche
imaginez tout le bénin nous allons tapis
c'est tout le bénin en cette couche de
sachets plastiques par notre
consommation de sachets par an alors
dans l'adagio ce sachet qui nous causent
des dégâts parce qu'ils ne se dégradent
pas il ne se dégrade pas les
spécialistes nice en 2000 5 ans en 2050
ce garçon qui va voir 38 ans en 2007 ans
j'ai une fille de 24 ans en 2050 les
enfants probablement les ventres aussi
ils n'auront plus de ensemble parce que
dans nos océans
parce que dans nos rivières dans nos
cours d'eau nous aurons plus de déchets
plastiques queue de poisson
aujourd'hui nous avons le septième
continent et vous imaginer quoi
pas en notre consommation de plastique
de déchets plastiques équivaut à plus de
8000 tonnes ce continent nos déchets ah
non non déchets place il comprend
présente plus de 8000 top 8 millions top
il est temps que le réveillon
il est temps que nous nous réveillons
parce que nous ne pourrons pas rester à
dire c'est pas de notre faute c'est de
notre faute parce que nous continuons
par utiliser tous les jours
ces sachets plastiques nous continuons
pas infecté et pas détruire notre
environnement tous les jours il est
temps parce que le futur
en réalité c'est aujourd'hui le futur
sans sachets plastiques c'est
aujourd'hui le futur sachets plastiques
c'est quand vous et moi nous serons en
mesure de dire non quand on m'a donné le
sachet plastique le futur je me rappelle
parce que quand on parle du futur il
faut bien parler du passé quand j'étais
petit et que j'allais acheter du pain je
me rappelle je sortais de la maison avec
un temps changent j'ai grandi en sortant
acheter avec le temps chambre
aujourd'hui personne ne sort de la
maison avec une tension
le passé quand nous moment aller au
marché
désolé avec les familles aujourd'hui
nous laissons nos paniers grand prouve
dans les marchés pour les supermarchés
et nous ressorte en avait 10 ans ce
chiffre va se passer quand on allait
acheter à manger on sortait de la maison
avec des volants aujourd'hui nous voyons
même des gens qui ont des vols mais
qu'il est même encore dans des sachets
le futur en sachet plastique
il est possible parce que dans le passé
nous avions nous avons vécu en sachet
plastique et aujourd'hui nous pouvons le
faire
le futur son sachet plastique c'est de
dire que chacun à son niveau et
responsable le futur sens affectif c'est
de ne pas dire oui mais l'autre minello
oui mais nous qu'est ce que nos prisons
avant de partir ce soir je vais vous
laisser être au tour de clef être sot de
clés où je vous donne trois clés qui
vont vous aider à vivre ce futur sans
sachets plastiques
le premier la première clé que je vais
vous donner ce soir
elle commence par la lettre m et ce
cadeau c'est refuser quand vous ne le
sache et bien sachez que la vendeuse
bien gentil tout étant dit je veux à
doubler le sachet attend des jumeaux le
couple est malhonnête
mais revoit dans un long trajet vous
devez être en mesure nous devons être en
mesure de dire ça chez la première clé
se refuser et ça c'est de notre
responsabilité
chacun de nous peut refuser la deuxième
clé ça commence aussi par mer ces
réduire si on joue plus nous utilisons
10h et painchaud réduisons déjà notre
consommation de sa fille si aujourd'hui
nous utilisons 10 et qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes en mesure d'en utiliser comme
seule se serait déjà 9 h et au moins par
jour 6 365 jours et la troisième clé que
je vous donnais ce soir c ommuniqué
reliques et tout ce que nous avons comme
ça chez autour de mots nous pouvons
fabriquer beaucoup de choses avec les
sachets autour de vos nous pouvons
énormément recyclés et il est temps que
pour le futur
aujourd'hui nous apprenions à rustiques
et au lieu de gérer tous les sachets que
nous avons et j'y terminerai même avec
un bonus et ce bonus commence aussi par
un air et c'est tout simplement devenir
repenser comment repenser notre façon
d'utiliser les emballages
nous allons nous rendre en réalité nous
en avons pas besoin nous en a aura
besoin c'est juste que ce qui est
habitué mais aujourd'hui nous sommes en
mesure de repenser de daisy en sachet
avant de venir y allant de laisser ma
place à une autre personne je voudrais
que nous repensions à ce futur à ce
futur où nos enfants vivront dans un
environnement prend à ce futur nous mais
nous allons protéger votre santé à ce
futur on n'ose océans ne seront pas 7e
continent de vigie classique et ce futur
vous et moi nous pourrons le construire
nous n'avons pas besoin de penser chacun
d'entre vous peut prendre cette décision
et j'espère qu'en sortant d'ici quand on
vous donnera un sachet ou quand vous
verrez un sachet vous allez le premier à
10h et sachez que vous remercie
[Applaudissements]